America is facing a growing epidemic
unlike we've ever seen it's causing
widespread panic roiling the stock
market and infecting our loved ones at
an alarming rate this pandemic is Donald
Trump saying stupid things about
coronavirus the virus
they're working hard looks like by April
you know in theory when it gets a little
warmer it miraculously goes away hope
that's true we have a totally under
control it's one person coming in from
China containing this will be a daunting
task here's how Trump saying stupid
things about coronaviruses spreads the
airborne particles travel through the
air and improve the value of sound waves
overwhelming your brain
sadly the group most vulnerable to
Donald Trump's saying stupid things
about coronavirus is the elderly but
don't panic there are simple steps to
protect yourself and avoid infection
first distract yourself by washing your
hands by surgical masks and place
another your ears avoid large gatherings
of angry white people and most
importantly do not touch your facebook
follow these simple steps and you too
can keep America safe from Donald Trump
saying stupid things about coronavirus
but I'm not gonna lie a lot of old
people are gonna get infected
you